what's our point now here's the thing we
could do this for a lot of numbers
right but the point is that someone down
the sun will be unbounded now
this um we started with i right now
where is that
where is that on this plane it's going
to be up right
these are where my imaginary numbers go
right so i would be up here
okay now just for the sake of interest
have a think about a number like this
minus one plus i
right where would that be well
here's the real part negative one
and here's the yeah it's kind of like a
coordinate system which is why i've got
my
x's right negative one plus i will be
over here okay
all right now rather than make you do a
whole bunch of these i'm going to show
you the shape that you get
if you color in all the bounded values
it looks like this this is gonna this is
gonna be hard okay
hold on hold on this is really hard to
draw
what i've got here and if i um if i
colored this in
like all of this is filled okay
what you've got is a set of numbers it's
a set of numbers for instance
here are some of the numbers zero
negative an eight negative one negative
heart
uh sum of the numbers like i negative
one plus i would be in here as well
right so what you've got here is a
graphic representation
of a set of numbers this whole family of
numbers
it has a name it's called
the mandelbrot set okay
named after a guy named benoir
okay now as you can see
you can see why i struggled to draw it
okay
hold on rewind we started this lesson we
walked in we said what topic are we
under
we're under the topic of fractals right
and then i started doing all this weirdo
algebra business
ah can you see what's going on now okay
in fact those of you who spent any time
on my website on my channel no
i'm kind of in love with this shape this
is my favorite shape
in all of maths okay and it's a fractal
right it's unfortunately
very hard to draw freehand okay but
what's really interesting about it and
is you can kind of see here but i'm
gonna zoom in further and show you more
right
can you see the scale
symmetry can you see it right it's
everywhere right
in fact let's go in a bit further let's
zoom in on a point like
here okay and you can see that a bit
better
right and you can see all of the same
shapes
right like so
and they go on and on forever you know
you'd expect it to kind of like
uh become boring after a while for
instance if you think about x squared
y equals x squared okay when you zoom
out
it's it's pretty interesting it's like
oh this cool well sorry i missed
this cool sort of parabolic shape right
but as you zoom in
right you start getting this shape which
is sort of it sort of flats out
and as you zoom in really really far you
just get like it looks like that
it's so flat across the bottom right but
you zoom into this thing
and it never flattens out it never
becomes simple you just get
more and more of the same kind of shape
it's crazy okay just like i mean just
like you would expected
with these guys
right if we were able to draw this
forever we could
zoom in forever and we could see this
kind of scale symmetry going on
you know often to infinity okay